well welcome to this new video
um this will be about the final day
of the rapid world championships um
held in astana kadasthan today
on the last day comprised of five rounds
again
and i already did videos on the first
two days
covering magnus carlsen's games he
really dominated the field on those
first two days scoring eight and a half
points out of ten so only
conceding three draws and winning seven
games
totaling to rating performance of close
to
three thousand i think it was maybe even
over three thousand three thousand and
eight or something
and uh second place was uh sergey
kayakin from russia
he had um i think one and a half points
less so seven out of ten and this last
day actually
yeah got interesting in terms of
the standings again so um i won't focus
on cars and games only but also show you
kayaking's games and okay this
um both showing both players games um
is a bit much so i won't um
do this in one video but in two videos
so this is part one and
please also check for part two which is
uploaded
simultaneously alright so let's start
this um 11th round saw carlsen playing
back against
grandmaster ismar gambitov
hope is ma gumbatov
the v is missing here um one of the
local guys i think from
kazakhstan and you see magnus being a
huge rating favorite here
okay let's see what happens um we've got
e4 e5 again
he played this throughout the event
and here he didn't went for the berlin
but for a6
and i really yeah looking at his games i
really
like like the games where he goes for
mainline
really much more than those where he
plays the berlin but
okay it's um nothing
nothing to do about this um
okay knight f6 castles bishop e7
rookie one we got just the normal
mainline
rulo pass stuff and here
the overwhelming main move is h3
the idea of h3 is to prevent this bishop
g4
move so that white actually can play
deform without having to worry about
bishop g4
in the game though white played d4
immediately
and this is quite an interesting
variation
and i'm um to be honest i'm surprised
that this is not more popular because
it's um yeah it's maybe not
um as good as h3 but it sets like
slightly um different problems
than h3 and black players often don't
know the
the know this variation too well so um
kind of interesting if you're a white
player i want to play the rule of pasta
and maybe look into this line it's not
so
well known um yeah carson played bishop
g4
which is um yeah the the correct move to
do
putting pressure on this this point on
d4
and white now played d5 react into this
pressure
an alternative here is bishop b3 which
is
also very very nicely playable
the tactical point here is that this
bishop
knight takes e4 is answered with bishop
d5
attacking both knights it's a very
useful
motif to remember this kind of unusual
fork of the two knights um okay so this
is bishop b3 but white went d5
black one knight knight to a5 attacking
the the bishop
of course white wants to keep this
important piece
plays bishop c2 and now black plays c6
attacking wide center
to gain some space on the queen side
white played h3 and now an important
move and a move that
black players really need to know black
played bishop
back to c8 now all the way back and
it's important to note that the move
bishop d7
really is a mistake here because of the
tactical shot knight takes e5
d takes e5 d6 and white regains the
piece with a nice advantage
he's got two bishops and then yeah
position that that is about to uh to
open up the default is open already
and black still has a somewhat clumsy
knight here
so white is much better here
so carson of course knew this played
bishop c8
white grabbed on c6 and now another
important move queen to c7
the idea is that black doesn't want to
take with the knight because the nylon
c6
isn't doing so much this pawn on c3
always
hinders the knight on c6 so what he
wants to do is
what exactly what we see in the game
white develops the knight
queen takes yeah the queen is not bad on
c6
putting some pressure on e4 potentially
and
controlling the d5 square so this is
what black wants to do he wants to
regroup the knight to b6
yeah all normal moves
bishop e3
yeah knight back to d7 to attack the c
pawn this is a slight weakness here in
white's camp
he covers it and knight to c5 and now
we see that black has quite some
pressure on e4
and all in all pretty pretty good
position
but there's nothing nothing dramatic yet
happening
just developing pieces and a5 black
tries to play on the queen side
here white played knight to g5
tickling this bishop so it retreats
black doesn't want to give up the bishop
pair
and now the white played c4 and i think
this
is um really yeah a bad move
the problem is um exactly what happens
in the game
black played to b form um an alternative
would have been to c4 um would have been
b4 which is interesting
quite a normal move in these kind of
positions because
you want to get rid of the knight and
possibly position your
your bishop on b3
to have a good diagonal and
this is quite quite interesting for
white still
so let's say knight to e6 as a possible
answer
and then you might go here and it's um
yeah i think maybe around equal
don't think that there's anything
dramatic happening here at least this
looks much better to me than
what was played in the game as mentioned
he played c4
magnus answered b form
rook to d1 maybe trying to do something
on d6
queen b6 bishop and a4 and this exactly
is the point
this pawn structure here
is a bit vulnerable to pressure on b3
this b3 point
now gets uh gets a real
gets real pressure by black combined
with the rook on a3 and the knight on c5
and if you look at the white's position
he cannot attack anything in black's
camp
black doesn't have a single weakness i
mean some some people might think okay
black has a weakness in d6 but
it's absolutely impossible to win this
pawn this is comparable
to to some positions in the sicilian
defense
where this pawn is supposed to be
weakness but it never gets lost
simply because it isn't a weakness
white cannot get any meaningful pressure
on this pawn
while black can easily attack the b pawn
and also
use the a file we see that it really
it's about it's a position that really
plays itself as black
driving away the knight and he just
maneuvers a bit and improves his pieces
bishop f8 so that you cover
h6 allowing maybe to play g6 at some
point
knight h4 okay you don't get to play
knight f5
and all the way back rook 8
yeah and we see that white really
doesn't have a plan
he can just sit and wait while black
improves his position yeah
it's really hard i i looked a bit at
this and um
besides the c4 move i'm not quite sure
what white really did wrong
but this is kind of a one-way street
position here like just has all the fun
and white cannot do anything
yeah and like has all the time in the
world to
put pressure yeah and now white is
actually forced to take on c5
nobody no big alternative b3 is not
coverable anymore
so he took and now his dark squares also
also weakened i guess the idea was to
transfer the knight to d5
we see this coming yeah needs to cover
here first
yeah it's really an invasion time here
on the a farm
yeah and knight g5 i think after this
it's very hard
for white to to defend this it was it
was um
not not very comfortable before but
this kind of structure i think really is
close to being lost black just
attacks b3 and has rook a1 rook a2
um just a terrible position white tries
a bit on the king side but
there's really nothing to do this is
also very nice move
putting the knight offside it doesn't
have a square and white cannot capture
here because of this little trick
winning a piece so white cannot take
and uh well this knight really is a
miserable piece now
he um played g3 to give this knight
a new square but after this here
there's the threat of knight takes b3
and white is in no position to prevent
this
so he went king g2
black took and okay some desperado
move here and after this white resigned
the queen's now come off and uh
black just wins about every piece on the
board
so a very uh very clean victory by
magnus here
um and i think really this c4 move
um yeah really really wasn't the way to
play this
because white really is passive after
this um
before i think was was still quite okay
so um
yeah everything all right so for
carlton's tournament he
won his first game of today and let's
see what um
what kayaking was doing the closest
pursuer he played evanshuk
ivan shook is having his typical kind of
up and down tournament
winning fine games and losing some games
that
no one really understands so um
let's see what happens in this game
so kayaking white playing evan shook
and we got the ruler pass again
and the one should play some
the same line that yesterday mamidyarov
played against
carlton but a little bit differently
because kayaking plays rookie one here i
think carson played d5
immediately knight f6
so black is not playing for a quick f5
after d5 i mean okay black cannot play
f5
anyway with the pawn on d4 but after
white plays d5
okay so white goes d5 rookie seven and
now um
this is a difference to carlton's games
game yesterday um
carson yesterday in this kind of
position it was similar
he just took on d7 and and played this
kind of position
or did you recapture with a knight i'm
not quite sure but he exchanged the
light squared bishop
um kayaking doesn't do so he just um
continues
to develop and allows ivan shook to play
bishop g4
which is not terrible for white yeah
it's just a different kind of setup
and now black all the way back he
doesn't want to give up his light
squared bishop i guess
and yeah we have a kind of king's indian
structure
this oops not the d4 square
this kind of pawns against black's
formation and
black has a typical king's indian
position
just a pawn on a6 and white has played
the moves rook
a1 e1 h3 and bishop on a4 which is
especially bishop on a4 is quite strange
so um it's interesting not so bad for
black i guess
okay let's see what happens he went
before immediately
black played knight h5 typical move to
prepare f5 bishop d2
covering this knight so that this
diagonal
um yeah is a bit a bit covered
a5 a3
king h8 yeah black preventing uh
preventing no preparing
preparing f5 typical kind of move to
get the king out of uh hans way
in c5 why does this has made quite some
progress already on the queen side
so black strikes back with f5
and now white took i think he didn't
want to
um yeah allow black to
set up a position where he might take
with the pawn
black now took with the knight if he
would have taken with the pawn
oops with the pawn then um
the issue is this knight takes e5 idea
this knight is hanging
so we didn't want to allow that
so black took with the piece and um
this is um quite an interesting position
here
um white plate knight to e4 normal
positional move
um one thing you need to look at is g4
it looks like draft it looks attractive
at first
attacking two pieces
but knight h4 really um is a problem for
white
this is attacked and if you take on h4
queen takes white is uh yeah white is
just lost here
if he grabs the knight
it's close to checkmate already rook to
h3 checkmate
yeah so this wasn't the way to go cannot
play g4
so 94 normal looking move
black exchanged here
and entered with this knight so uh these
two
pieces are quite close to white's king
so white decides to get rid of this
tonight he just captured it immediately
and played rook c1 so we have a position
now where
black managed to manage to activate
his own bishop here it's not hindered
anymore by pawn on e5
so black shouldn't be so bad off here
in this in this position
on the other hand white has nicely
centralized pieces
nice knight on e4 and also this bishop
is not bad at all
it controls some squares here and might
also retreat to c2 at some point
so about equal this position knight to
h4
trying to activate m it's answered by
knight g5
and we have an exchange
and black completes its development so
quite an
um quite an equal position i think but
it's not equal
on like that equal and a draw
it just means that yeah it's a sort of
dynamic equality
bishop c2 yeah black wants to keep his
bishop
and white centralizes nicely
yeah all pretty um normal looking moves
both sides trying to activate their
pieces and improve them
yeah h4 is a very direct move the ideas
could be h5
or maybe knight g5 putting some pressure
here on the king
side black routine retreated to d7
and knight g5 rookie 8
yeah everything quite normal
c6 yeah this is um
yeah very ambitious move i'm not sure if
it's
so great but it's very ambitious the
idea is
black black needs to capture
the idea was to set this set up this
kind of position
and um the idea is to play at some point
b6
to free the c pawn so white has a
very dangerous potential past pawn here
so c6 now that i look at it um yeah
seemed like a good idea it's not
terrible for black but um
it's a it's a good active idea by white
so ivan shook um instantly tries to get
counter play on the king side
pushing his g pawn
and knight d5 also very logical
attacking this pawn and black
pushes on
queen h5 check yeah and in this position
actually avenger commits a mistake but
it's very difficult
very difficult to see
i used of course an engine a bit too to
check this game
and the engine immediately recognized
this but for human very difficult
he played bishop h6 which looks
perfectly normal
what he should have done is queen to h6
and this is actually
completely okay for black it's so tricky
yeah this uh
this business here with b6 and so on but
um black um yeah it doesn't need to
worry too much in this position
if you look at the game however he
played bishop here
and then knight h4 and you see that this
kind of stuff is threatening
so he played king g7 and this this looks
perfectly
okay still it's not obvious what what
white should do
what we see now what happens he
retreated the bishop which is fine
black exchanged only one
and played g3 very typical move
to pry open also this diagonal so if
white
would take here he has his check
so what did y do he played knight f3
but in this position white actually had
a very strong move
he could play um here queen g6 check
but this is completely inhumane you
cannot
play this really a human with limited
time cannot play this move
we see what's what's coming it's the
typical computer line i show this
because it's very nice
black needs to take of course knight
takes
and what the rook supposed to do now
let's say he goes here
then white enters on e8
and this is very hard to play i think
for a human because
this knight seems terribly stranded on
g6 in a way
okay black might play a bishop here
and what should white play now in this
position
he has the super strong move b6 because
if black captures here you have b7
and if black takes here you can exchange
and c7
black would have this move yeah c7 but
you can play this absolutely crazy and
now the c
pawn is unstoppable
if black takes now
a c pawn just promotes yeah
no question this is not possible for a
human to play
so kayaking did what a normal person
should do
he got his knight back trying to
get it to some some decent square
black wind rook h8 now and you see that
white screen is
in a bit of a bit of a soft spot here
so he put it back to d5
bishop g4 yeah and here white
played the move queen to e4 very normal
looking move
he had a good alternative in b6 and
after this white might still be better
but it's very complicated to to analyze
so i don't want to get
into this too deeply let's um
revert to what happened he played
queen e4 now oops i'm not quite sure if
he did this
yeah eventually took on f3
white recaptured and he played bishop g5
and now you see that the move
queen h6 can be really a problem
white's king is in a bit of trouble here
so what should what should white do
he played rook to be one
and eventually played queen d4 in this
position
he could have played instead of queen d4
he could have played queen to h6
quite normal looking move and it's um
i don't really understand why i didn't
play it to be honest
it just looks like the normal move okay
it was down to a couple of seconds i'm
just saying
that it looks very normal it's not a
heavy criticism or anything
it's a very difficult position but it
looks very normal to
to sort of threaten this so what should
white do
if you look at this he could take
then you give a check here king moves
and now just capture here and
yeah black just has a devastating attack
here
it's got rook f8 coming or rook e8
also taking away the e file and then
then queen to h1 mate this is um
very dangerous king e2 rook f8 just a
sample line
and now it's uh it's basically over
black just has a huge attack on the dark
squares and white doesn't have any
counter play
um so all in all this queen h6
just would have won the game another
line to to look at is king f1 um
oops i forgot to show this
king f1 here then black has the nice
move rookie 8
taking away the e4
this kind of stuff
and it's over again
the fun thing is white also doesn't have
any
any kind of counter play and next move
it's uh
queen h1 and over yeah just
just terrible for white so queen h6
just would have won the game he played
queen d4 though
and white uh quickly covered f2
king move
queen e4 and we uh we get to an end game
where um black is slightly better
simply because he's got this active king
and the d-pawn
we see that on the clock times it was
like
down to a couple of seconds
so black tries to regroup the bishop to
b6
which is a very good idea because
let's say to to this diagonal because
this diagonal because it blocks the the
b pawn
black c5 bishop and you can try to make
progress with the d
pawn in the meantime so black is
slightly better but
it's not lost for white or something
black and black can press though
yeah and this is what happened rookie
three
bishop back so there's not much progress
made
really
rook c3 rook c4 rook c1
that just goes on a bit
and both sides are playing pretty well
here no
no big issues
so really not much happening the only
thing happening is that
kayaking played um very quickly and
gained
a couple of seconds here 10 second
increment per move
so um he had some comfortable time but
she vanchak was down to a couple of
seconds
and what happens now is pretty amazing
d4 rook c1 to b4
rook d1 and now white one on time
you one shook simply must have forgotten
the clock or
whatever so he simply lost on time
this position i didn't see a
webcam or anything if there was
something particularly awful happening
or
whatever he overstepped the time here
so white won a very uh strange end of
this game
which really should have ended in a draw
or at least not a wide win yeah white
wind was completely out of the question
so a very lucky win here for kayaking if
ivan shook
actually would have won this game then
magnus would have had a two and a half
point lead in the tournament
but now it was still um kayaking
um pursuing carlsen
very lucky win here
i'm sorry um okay
so um this was the first um
batch of games and uh it took much
longer than i actually intended so
i'm going to stop this here this um was
round 11
in just in one video and see the next
video for around 12.